sponsored by game flip a global
marketplace to safely by himself video
games and virtual goods check out the
description for a special offer
overhyped games that ended up being
terrible nothing's worse than spending
$60 of your hard-earned cash on a new
game only to be disappointed with the
product we've all been burnt by bad
games at one point or another publishers
and developers overhyped their games
making bold promises and placing false
hope into the minds and hearts of
consumers here are a few of the worst
offenders final fantasy xiv online
despite amazing graphics and music the
first version of final fantasy xiv
online turned out to be a massive
failure much like a cake that ends up
raw in the middle the game looked good
on the outside but was mostly unfinished
reviews & complaints got so bad that
Square Enix pulled the plug on
subscriptions and started over from
scratch
crafting a whole new game the resulting
reboot final fantasy xiv o'reilly born
took place five years after the original
reborn was well received by both gamers
and critics alike now let us never speak
of the failure that was Final Fantasy 14
online again Sonic the Hedgehog 2006 the
15th anniversary of Sonic the Hedgehog
came in 2006 and to mark this event Sega
released a game called well it was just
called Sonic the Hedgehog's
in it the rabid rodent was tasked with
saving a princess named Elise from dr.
Eggman
unfortunately the developers took a page
out of Sonic's book and rushed it the
end product was a clunky game with poor
controls long load times and a host of
glitches Sonic's all about speed but
there are some times when you'll want to
take it slow
Star Wars The Force Unleashed - The
Adventures of the anti-hero known as
star killer continued in Star Wars The
Force Unleashed - now you'd think that
getting to control Darth Vader's secret
apprentice at
who wield the force with unimaginable
strength would be a joy but you would be
wrong
even though it captured the same size
and scope of the original the Force
Unleashed to failed to deliver a good
story and was bogged down by repetitive
combat it's cool to hack at enemies and
mine trick them to their own doom but
when that's pretty much all you're doing
amid a weak story
it kills the fun this was not the sequel
you were looking for next one of the
PlayStation 4's launch titles knack had
the duty of setting up the consoles
future and success let's take a moment
to thank Sony that it wasn't the only
launch title for the ps4 because that
would have been a disaster neck looked
like it could have been fun but nope the
gameplay was terrible
players would die from the smallest
encounters and have to backtrack a ton
not only was the gameplay frustrating
but the story was so weak that your rage
at the crappy gameplay was cancelled out
by your utter boredom Tony Hawk ride
prior to its release Tony Hawk ride was
touted as the next major advancement in
video game interaction giving players a
physical board accessory that would
transfer your movement into the game but
it didn't work and we don't mean it
didn't work well it didn't work at all
there was such a delay between what
players did on the board and what
happened in the game that it was
basically unplayable Ryse son of Rome
developed by Crytek the makers of the
incredible Crysis series Ryse son of
Rome was set to be one of Xbox one's
coolest Kinect titles players took on
the role of a Roman centurion as he
embarks on a blood-soaked quest for
revenge but during development Ryze
underwent a bunch of changes that saw it
go from a connect heavy first-person
title to a third-person hack-and-slash
game when it was finally released rise
was beautiful but repetitive considering
it was a launch title for the Xbox one
it should have been much more than just
a button mashing bore case prior to its
release haze was heralded as a halo
killer but all it ended up killing where
our hopes for a good game this
first-person shooter cast players as
Shane Carpenter a soldier employed by a
corporation called men
then tell produces a drug called nectar
that allows soldiers to perform better
in battle but also warps their sense of
reality with hallucinations between it's
unimpressive level-design lame story and
it's underwhelming gameplay phases
developers must have been the one to
loosen ating thinking they could topple
halo duke nukem forever stuck stewing
and development held for about 15 years
Duke Nukem Forever was finally released
in 2011
unfortunately the long-awaited sequel to
Duke Nukem 3d had gamers wanting to send
it back where it came from simply put it
felt dated it was so bad that all
versions of the game scored in the 50s
on sites like metacritic and
gamerankings in the end this sequels
dismal reviews nearly tainted the memory
of the original not groovy aliens
colonial Marines probably the biggest
offender on this list aliens colonial
marines was so awful that fans were
unanimously outraged by its badness some
say it's one of the worst games to ever
be released by Sega the graphics were
lousy it had shoddy multiplayer
incredibly stupid AI unbalanced gameplay
and terrible sound the developer gearbox
software also claimed that the story was
going to be in continuity with the films
but it's lousy script revealed that to
be total nonsense
it was so poorly received in fact that
angry gamers actually filed a lawsuit
against Sega and gearbox if you find
yourself unfortunate to come and contact
with a copy of aliens colonial Marines
there's only one appropriate reaction
good night everybody thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to see
more videos like the one you just saw
and leave us a comment to tell us which
overhyped games you think should have
made this list